[Music]
the latest surrounding Lala and Carmelo
Anthony's surprising split caught up in
all that outside stuff because I know
what goes on behind closed doors the
stores close to the couple tells edy
their relationship has been rocky for a
while and that they haven't been living
together for months amid news of the
couple's separation rumors swirled up
the NBA star impregnated another woman
our source says Carmelo admitted to Lala
that he had hooked up with his
particular woman in Chicago but denies
that the pregnancy could be his baby
we're also told that Lala is aware of
Carmelo's cheating over the course of
their nearly seven-year marriage the
couple shares one child ten-year-old son
Keyon and we're told they're focused on
co-parenting and family right now
now that I'm a mom just that
unconditional love it's like nothing
that a woman could ever feel in her life
the source adds as of today there are no
plans to officially file for divorce
I know Melo and I have a strong
foundation we have a great relationship
and that's what matters
[Music]